talking about domestic politics uh now
earlier in the program we spoke to your
colleague at the conservative mp craig
whittaker he said that he thinks boris
johnson needs to step down because if
you make the law you can't then break
the law
he's right isn't he
i take a different view to craig i mean
he's a valued friend and colleague of
mine
but i do think that boris johnson is the
right person to be leading the country i
can't see
at a time when there are such big issues
like a european war like a
emerging and escalating economic crisis
that we would want to get into the
territory of a leadership election and
contemplating a changing leader that
doesn't seem to me to be in the next
i've heard this argument before that you
know we're in a time of war so we can't
change the leader i mean we aren't at
war are we obviously ukraine is at war
and but also there's president for
changing prime minister and leader even
when we are at war we changed leader
during world war one twice during world
war ii well i think there's a with
respect quite poor comparisons the times
that prime ministers have resigned in
the past have generally been because
there's been a catastrophic failure of
the government's central policy
some people would say that there's been
a catastrophic uh failure of public
confidence in the prime minister because
as we heard from a panelist quite a lot
of them think that he's lied
well your panel was actually quite split
from the conversation i heard and that
there were certainly people on the panel
who felt that this has been a sorry
episode that it's something that should
clearly not have happened however there
are very important issues facing the
country
and
it sounded to me as if some of your
panelists at least wanted us
to move on and concentrate on those big
issues that's how i feel i think that
politics now needs to be focusing on the
cost of living above all and in the war
in ukraine as well these are issues of
huge importance and we should be careful
about being diverted that's not to say
that we should trivialize what's
happened i think the prime minister is
embarrassed
mortified by what's happened he's
apologized to parliament i think that
was the right thing to do but i do now
think as a member of parliament i'm not
a member of the government that these
issues that the public really need to be
front and center now are the costs of
living are ukraine are those issues of
huge national international importance
you say you think the prime minister's
mortified is that from the public
statements he's made or have you heard
anything from him privately yeah i've
spoken to him privately and of course
i've listened to the various public
statements that he's made did you ask
him for reassurances then
i have asked him for reassurances there
is no way he would want this to have
happened he feels extremely embarrassed
that it has
i don't think that he would have
knowingly breached the rules he didn't
think that he was breaking the rules at
the time he didn't understand the rules
that he created well the incident that
we know most about the one that he's
received the fixed penalty notice for
you do have to remember that downing
street themselves briefed out
information about that in the days
immediately following almost two years
ago so at the time
they didn't think that they were in
breach of the rules that's not to
justify it because i think that it was a
mistake and shouldn't have happened but
it does give you a sense that
the prime minister was not setting out
to break his own rules this was i think
an honest mistake what i think is most
important now is that he does apologize
and that we focus on the big issues
quickly um labour of course tabling a
motion uh tomorrow to say that the
privileges committee should investigate
uh whether or not the prime minister
misled the house and would you support
that investigation
well the first thing is that the
government is actually tabling an
amendment to that which means that there
will be an opportunity to vote on this
as a member of parliament
once we're equipped with the final
report by sue gray and i think most
importantly of all the final verdict of
the police as to whether any further
fixed penalty notices are served so i i
would urge colleagues to wait
and to vote however they wish to once
they're equipped with the full facts i
do think there should be quite a high
threshold before you uh create one of
these investigations they're extremely
rare very few of these have happened i
can't think of a precedent whilst i've
been a member of parliament and so we
shouldn't do this for incidents which
are relatively minor which i think in
fairness the one for which the prime
minister has been served a fixed penalty
notice is it may be that when we're
equipped with the full facts on the sue
grey report that we change our minds or
i change my mind and there is actually a
case to have a full investigation by the
privileges committee but it sounds to me
as if the government has come up with a
perfectly reasonable answer at the
moment which is let's have that debate
when we all know what the true facts are